observa la siguiente imagen a que te
recuerda si a una sopa solo que esta es
especial porque los elementos que le
integran son números reales
los números reales se forman por dos
grandes grupos de números los racionales
e irracionales a su vez los números
racionales están compuestos por
fracciones decimales y además números
enteros
los números enteros pueden ser positivos
o negativos por ejemplo menos 3 - 2 - 1
0 1 2 3 dentro de los enteros se
encuentran los números naturales que son
conjuntos de números más reducidos los
números naturales son aquellos que
nombramos cuando comenzamos a contar 0 1
2 3
45 por último los números y racionales
son decimales que se derivan de una raíz
cuadrada o los decimales infinitos no
repetitivos como por ejemplo pi 3.14 15
92 65
vamos a descubrir de qué está hecha la
siguiente sopa qué tipo de números
reales podemos encontrar en la siguiente
expresión si tenemos que la sopa está
hecha de valores para x cuando menos 3
es menor que x y x es menor o igual que
5 entonces cuál es el valor de x esta
recta nos puede ayudar a encontrar el
valor de x la primera condición menos 3
menor que x nos indica que la solución
está del lado derecho del -3 ahora
consideremos la segunda condición que
nos dice que x es menor o igual a 5 por
lo tanto no debe rebasar el número 5 así
que ubicando los números que pueden dar
respuesta a este valor en este tramo de
la recta encontramos menos 2 menos 10 12
3 4 y 5 bien encontramos números enteros
y también naturales pero podemos
concluir que estos son todos los números
que dan respuesta al valor de x
veamos nuestra recta otra vez hey
estamos olvidando incluir los números
racionales que son los que se ubican
entre dos números enteros porque podemos
dividir un entero a la mitad después en
cuartos este en octavos y así
sucesivamente hasta llegar al infinito
vamos a identificar solo algunos porque
como podrás observar son muchísimos mira
aquí tenemos menos 2.3 menos 0.8 un
medio y 3.4 y seguramente tú podrás
nombrar más
esto quiere decir que algunos de los
números reales que encontramos en esta
expresión son menos dos puntos 3 - 2 -
0.8 0 1 un medio 2
de 3.445
esta sopa tiene como ingredientes los
números racionales les siguen los
enteros y dentro de estos encontramos a
los naturales qué números tiene como
ingredientes la siguiente sopa te invito
a descubrirlo